طيب مهمه ومهمه جدا همم باعتبارها اول
زياره همم للسيده الوزيره الى المغرب مره
اخرى مرحبا بك في هذا في هذا الزياره
الزياره لها مياه خاصه كذلك من مطلق انها
همم
تاتي في اطار تحضير
[موسيقى]
لقاءات على اعلى مستوى بين البلدين خلال
همم بدايه السنه خلال ثلاثه اشهر الاولى
من السنه المقبله
وتاتي كذلك من الطلاق الاهميه الخاصه اللي
همم لها جدلات الملك محمد السادس للعلاقه
همم
تقليديه المتجدره مع الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
اللقائنا اليوم كان مناسبه باش
بتعليمات من جلاله الملك منفخامه الرئيس
بشتغل ولا التحضير لهذه
الاستحقاق اللي غايكون على اعلى مستوى
ولكن كذلك كان مناسبه باش نشوف واقع
العلاقه
همم يعني
باسوس ها الصلبه
بمظاهر متعدده والمتنوعه ولكن كذلك ببعض
الاكراهات اللي مره مره كتوجهها وكيفيه
التعامل معها
بان همم
النقاشنا اليوم حول العلاقات الثنائيه
والضحك بانه هناك
في اييي وشهاده النهارده
تطابق حول الرؤيه
لتطور هذا العلاقه انطلاقا من
تعليمات جلاله الملك محمد السادس ولكن
كذلك بيا بانه هناك طموح مشترك لهذه
العلاقه
وكيفيه تطويرها
تحددنا كثير حول
الجوانب المختلفه اللي ممكن تشكل قاعده
لتطويل العلاقه
وتحدثنا كذلك حول
كيفيه اعاده احياء اليه التعاون سواء
الموجوده بين وزاره الخارجيتين او همم
الاليات التعاون والتنسيق المختلفه بين
البلدين
كان الاجتماع كذلك مناسبه باش نتحدثه على
بعض القضايا الاقليميه اللي كتبناه خاصه
في غرب افريقيا والساحل وغادي نتحدث اكثر
حول القضيه الاقليميه بعد قليل كذلك في
غداء العمل اللي غادي نديروا
المغرب وفرنس
مشتركه التحديات مشاركه في مناطق
مختلفه من العالم ل همم التعاملنا همم
كيكون فيه نوع من تبادل وجهات النظر في
بعض الاحيان نوع من التنسيق كذلك حول
مجموعه من هذه القضايا سواء في منطقه شباب
افريقيا في الشرق الاوسط
القاره الافريقيه همم
الفها دي واحد المحطه مهمه في الافق تحضير
الاستحقاقات المقبله وفي افق ال القفزه
النوعيه اللي كاينتظر الجميع في العلاقات
الثنائيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
هناك
لا يمكن ان نقارنها باي علاقه الاخرى
هنبدا همم اولا زرقاء المغاربه اصدقاء
المغاربه عن احترامي والصداقتي للزاء
المغرب وكذلك ان توجه بالتهنئه للفريق
المغربي المنتخب المغربي والذي بالفعل حقق
مصر رائعا بالامس
ذلك يبشر بالخير
همم
اتمنى ان تتمكن من تحقيق احلامكم وانا
متاكد متاكده بان الفهد الفريق
زرته
همم
اول مره اتي الى المغرب
لشؤون الخارجيه اريد
ان اسناني همم
مختلفه وهذا التشاور وكذلك رايت ان هناك
قارب كبير
لا حول
ولا قوه الا بالله ولكن امامكم واريد ان
اركز على الاهم واريد
على مبداين اساسيين يرخصصان في نظري
موقفنا اليوم همم
اراده مشتركه
لنظر نحو المستقبل
[موسيقى]
اولا همم النظر نحو المستقبل السيد الوزير
شرح ذلك هذه الزياره اليوم همم
[موسيقى]
رؤيه صاحبي الجلاله ورئيس جمهوريه فرنسا
همم في خلال الاتصال هاتفي بينهما في
اولبر عرض عن ذلك وكذلك همم
يوم الاربعاء مساء كان هناك تواصل بينهما
هو واريد ان نعرف عن ذلك المرحله التاليه
في زياره رئيس المغرب في تاريخ
علينا ان نحدده
ولكن نحن نعرف انه سيتم خلال ثلاث شهور
الاولى من السنه القادمه
نحن مستقبل
امر حمل وسميته همم
موسيقى على قاتل متينه بين بلدنا وقد كما
قلت ذلك سيد الوزير ينبغي انه قيمه
العلاقات القادمه
وانا مع السيد الوزير لدينا اروح
في هذا البرنامج
[موسيقى]
قوي اريد ان يشير الى موضوع
الشيء خلال شهر الاخيره
المغاربه اللي اعاده النشاط القنصلي بشكل
عادي وقد تم ذلك حتى ان نعيد علاقه كاملا
نعيد العلاقه الى وضعها الكامل بين بلدين
هدفنا وان نفعل مستوى
المتواجدين
ذلك اساسه علاقتنا الثنائيه ومحرك ومحرك
للمستقبل
وانا سعيده بانني
[موسيقى]
الى هذا الموضوع هناك كثافه للعلاقه بين
البلدين وهذه الكثافه بقيت قائمه دائما
حتى اخر السنه الاخيره في مجاله الثقافيه
والسياسيه
واقتصاديه والجامعيه ومجلات اخرى وقد
اتفقنا على ان نعمق من عملنا المشترك لكي
نبدا في مسارات تعاون جديده اضافه الى تلك
القائمه بيننا اليوم في مجالات اساسيه
بالنسبه للمغرب وفرنسا على هذه الصور وكما
اشار الى ذلك السيد الوليف اننا نرغب في
التقدم في وثيره جيده حتى يمكن
نتمكن من ان تصبح الزيارات همم الرئيس
على هذه المرحله الجديده
مهم جدا حول مواضيع متعدده ما بنسبه
القضيه الدوليه ونحن نتحدث نتناولها همم
هناك رؤيه واحده بين المغرب
وفرنسا همم يمكن لهذه العلاقه بان تكون
محركا لمعالجه بعض التحديات التي توجهنا
والمتصله
بالجوانب العالميه ولدينا مواقف قريبه من
بعد اربعه مثل السيد القائد الافريقيه
تناولنا كذلك بعض المواضيع خاصه
همم
المتعلقه
وقضيه اخرى مهمه متعلقه بالتنميه
النمو المستدام اييي وكذلك ونحرس البلدان
يحرسان على ذلكم مكافحه
قضيه
التحولوجي نحن بالفعل
اننا
الفعل
وانا ناس نعمل معا لاعداد الزياره الزياره
الاساسيه وحتى تكون الزياره في مستوى
الطموح
بالاضافه الى العلاقات الثنائيه مغربيه
وفرنسا في هذا العالم المعقد حتى اقول
خطير همم
عليه الصلاه والسلام واقع الذي نتحرك فيه
هذه
التوافق لينبغي ان نستخدمها
وعول مع بعض هذا التعاون الفرنسي هذه
الشراكه الفرنسيه المغربيه
[موسيقى]
عرفت كما قال ذلك السيد الوزير احنا عرفنا
ذلك يفترض بان تكيف تكيف الطرفان مع
التوقعات المشروع هذه المغرب هو المغرب
يتحول ولازال يتحول ويلعب دورنا ك
[موسيقى]
بيرا
ونقترح على المغرب
هو معنا زياره الرئاسيه
انا نسيت الوزير هو الفريقاني من خطيبه
نحن همم معاقبون العزم
للذهب الى مدى
عنه ونكتب صفحه جديده
لبعض لاننا نحن نعرف
وها اخر همم
الاقتصادي والنهوض بقيمنا والاستجابه
لتوقعات الشباب